south korea's military says north korea
has fired three ballistic missiles
authorities in seoul say they were
launched from pyongyang towards the sea
of japan and appeared to be preparation
for a possible nuclear test
the united states and south korea
carried out missile drills in response
u.s president joe biden has just wrapped
up a trip to asia during which he agreed
to new measures to deter north korea
and we can now talk to journalist gen
kwon in seoul south korea jen these
missile tests come hot on the heels of a
visit to the region by u.s president joe
biden do analysts there where you are
see a connection
well um it's not like a direct message
to the u.s per se because it has been
tested right after
12 hours after he had
left the region however it does send a
message to the region as in south korea
and the us and japan saying that oh
don't forget us i mean we still we are
still here and we have missiles and when
you see the missiles tested today most
used to be just ballistic missiles but
but the third missile that was fired
launched today was uh one was an icdn
which is
um immediate threat to um which is not
an immediate threat to the us
personality or personnel territory
but against human sanctions
i'm sorry um
yeah so icpm we're talking
intercontinental ballistic missiles here
that's quite significant
let me ask you jen how is seoul
responding to these tests we heard south
korea's new president yoon suk yule say
earlier this week that the age of
appeasing north korea is over
yes um the former president
uh moon has been a little bit more
gentle let's per se on handling north
korea and trying to coax them back into
dialogue but young sage has been long
saying during his campaign that he wants
to have a stronger hold on north korea
question is who can really do this in a
realistic manner
one of the things that they have shown
is as soon as yoon has been elected the
defense ministry has been giving more
details on what kind of missiles has
been launched uh from north korea before
it was unidentified projectiles today
they are telling the kind of missiles it
is the length and the height and also
saying that is a direct contradiction of
unresolution
and um and also
what we haven't seen before the past
years is joint thrills
as soon as
north korea launched missiles the u.s
and south korea did their own drill as
you mentioned um they tested their
south korean us missile units were
conducted in a combined surface to
surface missile launch in the east sea
which is so called the sea of japan
and uh both the south korean military
and the americans did uh launch their uh
their missiles uh some in five minutes
uh
uh different and some in a few seconds
okay
jen thank you very much that was
journalist jen kwon there in seoul